this predictor farm
it's an ak-47 how people say this is the
gold-plated ak-47 it's actually a like a
chrome gold plating it did come out one
of Saddam Hussein's palaces it was
brought back to the United States
illegally and so it didn't up in our
collection hi this is Danielle : with
the ATF National tracin Center I need
your assistance would a firearm trace
you know the question so why do you
trace a gun you know what's going to do
for you you find a gun in a crime scene
and the first question is what is ATF's
the only agency authorized trace guns in
the United States and we do it right
here in West Virginia not everybody is
necessarily aware that there's not a
national registration system for guns
ultimately if the guns recovered in a
crime we will go to an importer the
manufacturer and they'll say we sold it
to a wholesaler and that wholesaler say
we sold it to a retail dealer will call
that retail dealer up and that guy's
going to go look in his file for that
yellow piece of paper that you filled
out and pull it up and read the name off
of it to us and that's how it works
right
[Music]
somewhere along that chain of
distribution somebody might have gone
out of business and when they go out of
business they have to ship their records
here we receive somewhere around 2
million records per month when we get to
10,000 boxes in process GSA who owns the
building thinks that the floor will
collapse so they get stored in shipping
containers that we rent outside in
parking lot they come through the
loading dock area where they have to be
x-rayed all of the boxes are open
underneath a ventilated hood to make
sure there's no contaminants and then at
that point when we put in the inventory
and then given a location and then
stored so all those documents come in
and they've got to be sorted and then
they get scanned
apparently at the National farms
reference collection ATF this is our
vault area and we'll go in here and take
a look around as you can see it's like a
big bank vault then we have different
layers of security to get into it this
reference collection houses
approximately 17,000 firearms this is an
old single action revolver most people
would say it's a firearm because it can
fire a round of ammunition but according
to the law anything made enter before
1898 is not a firearm one of the very
few firearms in the United States that
is not a firearm they can fire these are
50 caliber type sniper sniper rifles and
they're also used for hunting believe it
or not out west and there's maybe
someone that's handicapped and they
can't walk as far they'll set them up in
an area and these things can shoot a
half mile or more when you start to go
to microfilm now you're talking 40
minutes a shot this is about a hundred
and forty people right now that just
look at microfilm about half of them are
on day shift and the other half are on
night shift that's all they do it does
take a little bit of getting used to I
know that when I first started I kind of
felt a little seasick because once you
get going the material does get really
quick so you do get a little bit
disoriented roll of microfilm here the
tracing Center usually has ten thousand
documents and one dealer who was in
business 15 years he might have six
rolls of microfilm you can divide it by
six and let one person look at each each
roll but at the end of the day because
you only have one roll it's one guy one
guy has to look at ten thousand pieces
of paper to find the gun
here's some of the other guns that we
run across the new years this is a
cigarette pack and as you can see it
actually fires rounds of ammunition this
looks like a normal briefcase that
someone's carrying around and you can
see there's a hole there and there's a
button here to fire it and here's a cane
gun same situation you just load it and
you're walking along and then if a wild
animal or something comes to you you
know you have some type of weapon in the
last several years a lot of dealers
particularly bigger corporate operations
maintain their records and computer
files well that's great right you just
take those electronic records and you
can load them into your system well it
doesn't work like that because let's
just imagine a dealer who kept all this
records on an Excel spreadsheet an Excel
spreadsheet is sortable by name we can't
have anything that's searchable and
sortable by name
basically what we're doing now is we
have to have computer technicians
isolate these records and then we've got
to turn it into something that's not
searchable so they got to convert them
into PDFs and then they actually convert
that to a tiff and then they tagged it
with gun descriptions and FFL number and
then load it in to the system
hi this is Danielle : with the ATF
National tracin center I need your
assistance with a firearm trace